benvenuti in un nuovissimo come avrete
notato oggi parliamo dei pigiami no
scherzo oggi parliamo di outfit di
natale perché come ho fatto l'anno
scorso anche quest'anno volevo darvi
qualche suggerimento qualche consiglio
per gli outfit di natale perché anche a
natale
noi ragazze e anche tanti ragazzi dicono
ma cosa ci mettiamo in particolare
quest'oggi shiori signori vi presenterò
4 outfit uno un po più semplice sportivo
uno un po più divampò dolce gabbana mood
1 oro nero ovviamente è l'ultimo molto
bon ton molto kate middleton
siete pronti
partiamo subito con il primo outlet
ecco a voi il primo outfit che è quello
che è definito un po più semplice e
sportivo ma non per questo non pazzesco
perché io lo adoro
ho preso questi pantacollant da zara
quest'anno il tartan che è questa
fantasia qui sta spopolando quindi sono
sicura che avete già comprato qualcosina
di tartan e abbinato sopra questa t
shirt di asus che avevate già visto in
un lido è passato con questi due lecca
lecca qui sopra che sono super super
carini super super natale direi poi
ritarda rosso
figurati e proprio natalizi simo in
questo nuovo aggettivo presentato e
sopra potete abbinarci ovviamente se 93
magliette del gender qualche tigrotto
nero bianco vedo verdone non sono di mi
to i colori proprio classici del natale
sono strub inabili al tar altro rosso
quindi sbizzarritevi e fatemi sapere se
questo look sportivo
vi piace e lo utilizzerebbe passiamo al
secondo pit
ed eccoci qui con il secondo outfit che
quello che ho definito meno sobrio
chiuda diva più dolce gabbana mood
perché è un fantastico abitino compreso
summit guided di pizzo rosso rosso
natale pizzo eleganza non è volgare
infatti copre tutto quello che deve
coprire e non è eccessivamente scollato
quindi anche per una cena in famiglia
può andare bene e poi un pizzo con una
trama così fida non è una rete da pesca
quindi non rischiate di fare brutta
figura con i parenti perché super super
super classi ma passiamo al terzo out di
oro nero
ed ecco a voi il terzo outfit cioè la
fit oro nero che
e più che altro oro bianco e nero perché
è composto da questo fantastico abitino
di zara nero con dei piccoli dettagli e
applicazioni oro come i bottoni queste
catrini catenine e abbinato a questa
dolce vita bianca costine ma potete
metterci qualsiasi altra cosa una dolce
vita rossa una prop top quello che
volete
dettaglio non indifferente questo
fantastico basco di velluto nero che da
un tocco di classe in più un tocco di
charme in più
infatti questo oltre a oro nero potrebbe
essere definito come un outfit bon ton e
è un po chanel per tutti coloro che non
vogliono usare con colori tipicamente
natalizi come il rosso come il verdone e
vogliono rimanere nel total black che è
uno stile di vita per tantissimi ragazzi
e ragazze passiamo al quarto outfit che
ancora più bon ton e ancora più kate
middleton quarto ed ultimo outfit kate
middleton ci sono allora sotto questo
fantastico cappottino che avete chiesto
in tantissimi dove ho preso è di ralph
lauren e l'ho utilizzato nel video le
tipiche frasi di natale in cui facevo
l'inviata speciale di barbara d'urso una
volta tolto questo cappottino abbiamo
questa gonna di lana cotta panna con
questi dettagli neri rossi e oro molto
gucci e sopracciò abbinato questo top di
pizzo semi trasparente ma è quella
trasparenza che non è volgare mi
raccomando se utilizzate un top del
genere o o reggiseno collocarne o nero
non mettiamo colori di poe fucsia perche
poi mi va di a tutto lo charme i tutto
il bon ton
ovviamente consiglio questo outfit a
tutte coloro che insomma passeranno un
natale di charme magari andranno a
festeggiare in un
ristorante pregiato con la propria
famiglia ma anche a tutte coloro che
vogliono
concorrere al trono di scozia o di
galles
scegliete voi per tutte le future
principesse all'ascolto questo e l'out
fit per voi per il vostro natale
purtroppo siamo arrivati alla fine del
video spero vivamente che uno di questi
outfit vi abbia ispirato e sorpresa
finale c'è un quinto outfit che posso
proporvi il pigiama quello va sempre
benissimo no presentarsi per aiutare in
pigiama potrebbe essere la nuova moda va
e marina se non avete ancora fatto
ricordatevi di iscrivervi al canale
cliccare sulla campanella che trovate
vicino al tasso di iscrizione per
rimanere sempre aggiornati su tutti i
nuovi video e mi raccomando seguitemi
anche su tutti gli altri social facebook
instagram e tic toc vi mando un bacione
buone feste e ci vediamo nel prossimo
[Musica]